♪
>> Jesse: WORDS CAN BE POWERFUL
IF YOU USE THEM CORRECTLY.
THEY CAN RALLY A NATION.
>> I CAN HEAR YOU.
THE REST OF THE WORLD HEARS YOU.
AND THE PEOPLE.
[CHEERS]
>> AND THE PEOPLE WHO KNOCKED
THESE BUILDINGS DOWN WILL HEAR
ALL OF US SOON.
[CHEERS]
>> Jesse: WORDS CAN INSPIRE A
GENERATION.
>> THAT'S ONE SMALL STEP FOR
MAN.
ONE GIANT LEAP FOR MANKIND.
>> Jesse: WORDS CAN EVEN WIN
OVER SOMEONE'S HEART.
>> I LOVE YOU.
YOU COMPLETE ME.
NOT JUST -- SHUT UP.
JUST SHUT UP.
YOU HAD ME AT HELLO.
>> Jesse: SOME WORDS ARE SO
POWERFUL YOU CAN'T EVEN SAY THEM
ON TV.
>> THERE ARE WORDS THAT YOU CAN
SAY NO PROBLEM.
THAT PENTAGONNOGRAPHY.
NO ONE HAS EVER GONE TO JAIL FOR
SCREAMING TOPOGRAPHY BUT THERE
ARE SOME WORDS YOU CAN GO TO
JAIL FOR.
I WAS TRYING TO FIND OUT WHICH
WORDS THERE WERE ALL OF THEM.
I WANTED A LIST BECAUSE NO ONE
GIVES YOU A LIST.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
THEY DON'T GIVE YOU A LIST.
WOULDN'T YOU THINK IT WOULD BE
NORMAL IF THEY DIDN'T WANT TO
SAY SOMETHING TO TELL YOU WHAT
IT IS.
NOBODY EVEN TELLS YOU WHEN YOU
ARE A KID WHAT THE WORDS ARE
THAT YOU ARE SUPPOSED TO AVOID.
YOU HAVE TO SAY THEM TO FIND OUT
WHICH ONES THEY ARE.
[BLEEP] OH [BLEEP]
>> THAT'S TWO.
OH, MA, THAT'S ENOUGH TRIAL AND
ERROR.
PLEASE MOM GIVE ME A LIST.
>> Jesse: BE CAREFUL WHAT YOU
WISH FOR.
STANFORD UNIVERSITY SPENT THE
LAST 18 MONTH COMING UP WITH A
LIST OF WORDS YOU ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO SAY ANYMORE.
IT'S PART OF THEIR ELIMINATION
OF HARMFUL LANGUAGE INITIATIVE.
AT THE TOP OF THE LIST, STANFORD
ISSUED A WARNING, THIS WEBSITE
CONTAINS LANGUAGE THAT IS
OFFENSIVE OR HARMFUL.
PLEASE ENGAGE WITH THIS WEBSITE
AT YOUR OWN PACE.
SO "PRIMETIME" WOULD LIKE TO
ISSUE OUR OWN VIEWER WARNING, IF
YOU HAVE CHILDREN WATCHING, THEY
SHOULD LEAVE.
FIRST UP, SAYING AMERICAN IS NOW
BANNED.
THEY WANT YOU TO SAY U.S.
CITIZEN INSTEAD WHY?
STANFORD CALLING PEOPLE FROM THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA A
AMERICAN IS A PROBLEM IT
INSINUATES THAT THE U.S. IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT COUNTRY IN THE
AMERICAS.
FOX NEWS ALERT.
WE ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT
COUNTRY IN THE AMERICAS.
ZELENSKYY ISN'T GOINGS ASKING
GUATEMALA POOR MONEY.
HE IS COMING HERE.
WHAT OTHER WORDS DID STANFORD
BAN?
GANG BUSTERS.
YOU SHOULD USE VERY SUCCESSFUL
AGAIN.
GANG BUSTERS INVOKES THE NOTION
OF POLICE ACTION AGAINST GANGS.
WE WOULDN'T WANT TO OFFEND THE
CRYPTS.
NEXT WORD YOU CAN'T SAY
IMMIGRANT?
SAY NON-CITIZEN OR PERSON WHO
HAS IMGREATED.
FOR EXAMPLE, 5 MILLION
NON-CITIZENS CAME INTO THE U.S.
ILLEGALLY SINCE BIDEN TOOK
OFFICE THE PHRASE BEATING A DEAD
HORSE IS ALSO BANNED.
YOU SHOULD SAY REFUSING TO LET
SOMETHING GO.
STANFORD SAYS THIS EXPRESSION
NORMALIZES VIOLENCE AGAINST
ANIMALS.
THE HORSE IS MET FORK CALL AND
ALREADY DEAD.
WHERE IS THE VIOLENCE?
I DON'T KNOW.
ANOTHER BANNED WORD,
GRANDFATHER.
INSTEAD CALL HIM LEGACY.
STANFORD SAYS GRANDFATHER HAS
ROOTS IN THE GRANDFATHER CLAUSE
WHICH SOUTHERN STATES USE TO
DENY VOTING RIGHTS TO BLACKS.
BY THIS LOGIC ANYTHING THAT
INVOLVES SLAVERY SHOULD BE
BANNED.
WE CAN'T SAY DEMOCRATS ANYMORE.
GRANDMOTHER IS STILL OKAY TO USE
THOUGH.
GRANDMOTHERS MAKE SURE TO SIGN
ALL YOUR CHRISTMAS CARDS FROM
GRANDMA AND LEGACY.
STANFORD EVEN BANNING SOME OF
THE LEFTENS FAVORITE WORDS LIKE
"TRIGGER WARNING" THEY SAY IT'S
TOO TRIGGERS.
USE CONTENT NOTE INSTEAD.
AND PREFERRED PRONOUNS IS OUT,
TOO.
NOW YOU JUST SAY PRONOUNS.
BECAUSE THE WORD PREFERRED
SUGGESTS YOU ARE ABLE TO CHOOSE
YOUR GENDER IDENTITY.
I KNOW.
THIS IS CONFUSING.
SO LET'S MOVE ON.
KAREN IS BANNED.
INSTEAD OF CALLING SOMEONE A
KAREN.
YOU SHOULD CALL THEM AN ENTITLED
WHITE WOMAN.
I THINK KARENS WOULD RATHER BE
CALLED KARENS.
YOU WERE NEXT, BLIND STUDIES
BAN.
IT'S HURTFUL TO BLIND PEOPLE.
THEY WANT YOU TO SAY MASK STUDY
INSTEAD.
THESE PEOPLE LOVE MASKS.
THE THREE MASKED MICE JUST
DOESN'T HAVE THE SAME RING TO
IT.
WHAT ELSE CAN'T YOU SAY?
ADDICTED.
INSTEAD, USE HOOKED OR DEVOTED.
HUNTER ISN'T JUST THE SMARTEST
GUY JOE KNOWS HE IS THE ALSO THE
MOST DEVOTED.
THE WORD MASTER IS ALSO BANNED.
AS IN MASTER BEDROOM.
THEY WANT YOU TO SAY PRIMARY
INSTEAD.
DO YOU THINK STANFORD WILL BE
GIVING REFUNDS TO ALL THOSE
STUDENTS WHO PAID 10 GRAND FOR A
RACIST MASTER'S DEGREE?
I DON'T KNOW.
THEY DON'T WANT US TO USE CHIEF
ANYMORE.
THEY SAY CALLING A WHITE PERSON
CHIEF TRIVIALIZES REAL INDIAN
CHIEFS.
AND YOU CAN'T CALL AN ACTUAL
INDIAN A CHIEF.
THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO ARE ALLOWED
TO USE THE WORD CHIEF ARE
INDIANS.
AND RANDY LIVINGSTON WHO IS
STANFORD'S CHIEF FINANCIAL
OFFICER.
THERE IS ONE WORD THAT YOU
SHOULD NEVER SAY UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCE, EVER.
IT'S SO BAD THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE
A REPLACEMENT FOR IT.
BRAVE.
IT CULTURALLY APPROPRIATES
NATIVE AMERICANS BECAUSE ONLY
NATIVE AMERICANS WERE BRAVE.
THERE'S A SINGLE, NOT A SINGLE
OTHER ETHNIC GROUP ON THE PLANET
EVER THAT DEMONSTRATED BRAVERY.
WE CAN'T EVEN CALL FANG FANG
BRAVE FOR SLEEPING WITH ERIC
SWALWELL.
MAYBE I'M JUST OLD FASHIONED OR
MAYBE I JUST LOVE THE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE MORE THAN STANFORD.
BUT, WE SENT A PRODUCER OUT TO
SEE WHAT YOU THINK
♪
>> SAN FRANCISCO BAY FORD CAME
UP WITH A LIST OF WORDS THAT
THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO GO
THROUGH THAT LIST FIRST UP.
WHAT IS WRONG WITH THE WORD
AMERICAN?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
>> WHAT'S WRONG WITH SAYING THE
WORD AMERICAN?
WE ARE IN AMERICA, RIGHT?
>> IT TAKE IT AWAY.
>> I DON'T FIND ANYTHING WRONG
WITH SAYING AMERICAN.
>> HOW ABOUT IMMIGRANT?
WHAT'S WRONG WITH THAT?
>> IMMIGRANT WELL THAT'S KIND OF
THE NAME THAT'S BEEN USED FOR A
VERY LONG TIME.
>> THERE ARE PEOPLE IN WORLD
THAT LIKE TO USE WHERE PEOPLE
HAVE COME FROM AND TO PUT THEM
DOWN FOR THAT.
>> IS IT OFFENSIVE?
>> NO.
AND IT SHOULD NEVER HAVE BECOME
OFFENSIVE.
>> A PERSON THAT IMMIGRATED IS
THAT BETTER DO YOU THINK.
>> A PERSON THAT IMMIGRATED?
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
>> WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE?
>> IT'S JUST THE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE AND HOW YOU CHOOSE, YOU
KNOW, DID THEY IMGREAT?
OR ARE THEY IMMIGRANTS?
>> WHAT IS WRONG WITH CALLING
SOMEBODY A KAREN?
[LAUGHTER]
>> I HAVEN'T HEARD OF IT.
>> I FEEL HURT WHEN I HEAR THAT.
>> I LOVE USING THAT AS JUST
LIKE A FUNNY TERM LIKE JOKINGLY.
>> PERSONALLY AS WOMAN OF COLOR
WHO HAS HAD TO DEAL WITH A FEW
KARENS I FIND TO SAY THE WORD
KAREN.
>> WHO KNOWS THE NEXT GEN OR IN
10 YEARS THEY WILL BE CALLED A
BARBARA.
>> OH, INSTEAD OF CALLING
SOMEONE KAREN, STANFORD WANTS
YOU TO CALL THEM AN ENTITLED
WHITE WOMAN.
IS THAT LESS OFFENSIVE?
>> NO, THAT'S STILL PRETTY
OFFENSIVE.
>> I WOULD SAY INCREDIBLY MORE
OFFENSIVE NOW YOU ARE
INDIVIDUALIZING THAT RACE.
>> I WOULD CALL THEM BOTH A
KAREN AND ENTITLED WHITE WOMAN.
>> WHATTENS WRONG WITH THE TITLE
GRANDFATHER?
>> NOTHING.
>> I HAVE NEVER HEARD ANYTHING
WRONG WITH THE TITLE OF
GRANDFATHER.
>> WELL, THAT'S THE WORD FOR
SOMEBODY THAT IS OUR FATHER'S
FATHER; IS IT NOT?
>> MY HUSBAND IS A GRANDFATHER.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY THAT?
>> I DON'T THINK THAT'S
OFFENSIVE AT ALL, PERSONALLY.
>> DO YOU AGREE WITH STANFORD'S
WORDS THAT ARE OFFENSIVE?
>> I DON'T REALLY BELIEVE IN
REMOVING WORDS FROM DICTIONARIES
AT ALL.
>> STANFORD IS KIND OF OUT OF
TOUCH, KIND OF ELITIST.
>> LET'S NOT KEEP CHANGING THE
DEFINITIONS OF THESE WORDS.
LET'S GET -- STAY WITH WHAT IT
MEANS AND STOP MAKING IT
OFFENSIVE.
>> Jesse: MY GRANDFATHER WENT TO
STANFORD UNIVERSITY.
I MEAN MY LEGACY.
AND I WASN'T EVEN SMART ENOUGH
TO GO THERE AS A LEGACY.
BUT, WHY SEND JESSE JR. TO
STANFORD?
NO.
I DON'T WANT TO FLY THAT FAR TO
SEE THEM AND, TWO, THEIR
FOOTBALL TEAM IS TRASH.
AND, THREE, STANFORD HAS BECOME
A FED BOOT CAMP.
STANFORD IS INDOCTRINATING
SPEECH POLICE MATRICULATING THEM
INTO SILICON VALLEY WHERE THEY
WILL SPREAD THEIR COMMUNIST
SPEECH CODES.
PRESIDENT KENNEDY, JUSTICE
SANDRA DAY O'CONNOR THE GUY WHO
STARTED GOOGLE THEY ALL STUDIED
AT GOOGLE.
A FEW WEEKS AFTER THESE KIDS
TOSSED THEIR CAPS INTO THE AIR
THEY WILL BE RUNNING TECH
COMPANIES AND WRITING LAWS.
LET'S HOPE THEY DON'T BRING THE
LIST OF BANNED WORDS WITH THEM.
TONIGHT, I AM CALLING FOR A FAKE
BOYCOTT OF STANFORD UNIVERSITY.
DO NOT APPLY THERE.
DO NOT DONATE.
DO NOT HIRE STANFORD GRADS.
GUTFELD, WHO WENT TO BERKELEY,
SA